Bốn ngày báo năng ra quần thảo ở vị mắc bộ,
mơ lớn lên tiếp chút xuống mình bắt,
khiến nhiều tình thành gập sau có nơi 2 và mẹt,
bình đến ngày 20, 30, khiến hàng người thiệt mặt,
một người bị thương, hơn 6,5 năm,
gần 5 người nhà bị gập và khoảng 20,000 bị tré khách.
Lạng sơn chua anh hưởng nận nhất với hơn 40,000 về chăm nhà bị gập.
Thao có trợ này, mình nhìn bù trên chào thức trạng,
hình khách của hợn gất sả và ngọt lên gần định nóng nhà luôn,
bao phụ còn năng nước và nước.
Cái điều phương phải sử tắn gần bày gì hộ dân,
chua ở lạng sơn và bắt ninh.
Tàn nghe an, sát lờ xây ra trên cuộ mùi sấu và cuộ bày,
khiến một số tuyến đường vào các sát mình nguy phía tầy bị chia khách.
Quảng ninh cũng khi nhận só mi chính điểm sát lờ,
hàng trong hết tạng mà mồ, kê ăn quà bị anh hưởng.
Đến nghe hai 1,5 tháng tâm,
tâm bạo ở vùng biển phía nằm đặc khu và klong vi,
sức gió mạnh nhất cấp tâm dật cấp mời.
Dự báo đến ngày hai 1,5 tháng tâm,
báo đi vào đất liền Trung Quốc và suy yếu thành áp thấp dẫn nơi.